okay we're live hi good morning
by the way today I have on the t-shirt
that I bought in Salvador da Bahia when
I visited Brazil just such a sunny place
the beautiful beaches nice restaurants a
little bit challenged in terms of the
amount of favela beaches so my memories
of my visit to Brazil but today I want
to talk about something that happened on
the weekend so my wife I went to visit
her sister in fact I drove her there his
sister lives on the outskirts of LA and
we have Chinese meal there and then I
drove home and so I'm on my own for a
few days and so I decided I would
basically have this you know composite
lemonade before that I would clean it
normally I just vacuumed ur sweep and
did a bunch of stuff around the house
and that result of which is and then I
hit some balls on the driving range and
I worked out at the gym and then I
cooked up some dinner
oh no I listened to five hours of Arabic
five hours now I think the average
marathon you know the winners they run
in two hours and a half or something but
the average ordinary person who
participates in a marathon may take four
or five hours to complete the marathon
and there's no question that five hours
of concentrated listening while doing
other tasks you know is kind of
Bombardier in your brain with the
language now I was listening to material
that I had read and listened to before
our mini stories but the ministers are
full of the structure of the language
the grammar of the language the most
common verbs of the language it's not
very interesting to me except that I am
focused on getting a better sense of how
the language works which is something
that I like to do despite
you know my belief in compelling content
and sometimes I think I'm I'm kind of
getting less and less out of these many
stories every time I listen to them so I
do try to go forward but in the case of
Arabic it's difficult because there's a
big gap between what I can comfortably
deal with and the more difficult content
so at any rate I listen to five hours
and and it says so on my on my stats and
you know I know in Japan at one point
they had this sort of listening marathon
was a bit of a slogan and they
encouraged people to listen for a
thousand hours you know and if you get
to that point then then again it's all
about you know getting the language to
penetrate your brain to get because you
have to rely on the brain to a large
extent through reading and listening to
start picking up on things because it's
it's kind of more difficult to
consciously put the knowledge of the
language in our brain like here's this
grammar rule and here is this list of
words we're gonna put them in our brain
it doesn't quite happen that way it
happens through this process of
absorption and assimilation now so I'll
show you so I just wonder how people
feel like we should run some kind of a
listening marathon at length whether it
be you know amount of listening in a
month and a day in the week push people
to to listen more because every time
I've had those of you here my viewers
say please analyze my high profile at
length what I find every time is that
people don't listen enough know it is
possible that you're doing your
listening outside of link so you know if
you have an audiobook or you have some
other material you're listening in
iTunes or or you're listening somewhere
else then Lincoln is not keeping track
of it although you can manually add that
in the advantage with playlists and
that's why I have become a big fan of
the playlist is that the system will
automatically track when you open the
lesson and listen and when you listen on
your playlists so if you listen 10 15
times to these different stories that
all adds up to the total amount of
listening that you're doing so I always
make a point if I study a lesson on
length that has audio then I add that to
a place and I kind of get rid of some of
my older playlists we can only keep one
hundred items unfortunately in the
playlist but I removed some and put the
new guys in there so that's kind of my
thought this is listening marathon I
don't know where we go with that we've
had our you know we have our 90-day
challenges and different kinds of
challenges by the way I just another
thing I thought I would do when I
finished my 90-day challenge here of
Arabic and Persian at the end of April
and the whole month of May is gonna be
my Slavic languages challenged 30 days
particularly Russian and Ukrainian since
I'm gonna visit Ukraine in the second
half of May and my goal is to improve my
accuracy in the language because Slavic
languages a lot of it has to do with
sort of accurate use of cases accurate
use of verbs of motion and accurate use
of a verbal aspect so Chasseur are the
three things you know yeah I can acquire
more words but I would like to be more
accurate so month of May I'm gonna try
to focus on becoming more accurate in
Russian Ukrainian I might even touch a
bit on polish anyway let me just have a
look at this issue of of the listening
marathon and look at my statistics so
let's just share the screen here so okay
one of the problems by the way that I've
had and I don't know if anyone can help
me is you know I bought this audio book
the 7 secrets of Highly Effective People
in Arabic but I can't get it into link
and I'm trying to figure out how to do
it I bought the audio book at at
audible.com and I bought the e-book at
Amazon so it's in my Kindle but I'm I
just can't figure out how I get it I
try this someone sent me this PDF file
but this is not in a format that that I
can import the link so I'm kind of stuck
there if anyone has any suggestions that
would be much appreciated now if I go
here there was discussion of it on our
forum as well but if I look at my let's
go Arabic here um and if I look at my
profile and so last week I listened 5.7
hours most of that was yesterday
yesterday so if I look at the last three
months 42 hours of listening a little
bit below my target I should increase my
listening now I do have some items that
are on an iTunes playlist that don't
haven't been added in here that's not a
lot if in Japan they're running as
marathon a thousand hours of listening
and that's like almost a hundred hours a
month and I'm not doing that I'm only
doing 15 hours a month let's say in the
last six months so yeah I'm running ten
hours a month of listening ten hours a
month that's there when you think of it
you know that's ten dollars a month
that's a little over two hours a week
which is you know half hour a day or so
missing a day or so so I don't know what
what we can do with this whether we
should try to run some kind of a
marathon really go for just listening in
order to increase the awareness of the
importance of listening okay so I just
wanted to talk about the idea that we
force ourselves to do more listening
either to have a five hour day of
listening
I mean you know obviously if you listen
five hours a day every day that would be
an awful lot of listening that's 35
hours a week that would get us up to
that hundred a month that would get you
out to that 1,000 a year I'm sure that
would a major impact on our sort of
sense of the language there's also the
issue of what we would listen to to some
extent we can listen to you know things
like the many stories where we're
focusing on the structure of the
language the grammar but we also have to
have this more interesting material
again this whole issue of repetition and
and novelty for the brain so that's kind
of what I wanted to say and get your
impressions on and now I am gonna have a
look at the questions all right what do
you think about talking yourself to
improve the way you're speaking a
foreign language I haven't really done
that I mean occasionally if you find
yourself repeating certain phrases but
if you're talking about okay so talking
yourself so you have a dedicated amount
of time you can spend on on a language
it's still an hour a day or whatever so
I am going to spend that time so if it's
not dedicated learning time if it's in
the car cleaning house that I'm
listening if it's dedicated learning
time I'm reading and linking am I gonna
take time away from that to speak I
don't think so but other people do that
fine hi what are the most some of the
most pleasant experiences you've had
thanks to foreign language maybe Caesar
thought this is why I learn languages
lots of them most recently in Vancouver
if I say a few words a person to a store
clerk they're delighted to hear me
however poorly I speak Berger you know
conversations with the taxi drivers in
Morocco traveling in Romania with my
driver and we were speaking Romanian
obviously living in Japan for nine years
doing business in
and driving with my customer for an hour
on the expressway and we were just
talking about all kinds of subjects it
comes a point when you're not even aware
that we're speaking in foreign language
especially with Japan like I just had
customers I had one guy in Nagoya bought
newsprint
I had to go down there he'd like to
discuss philosophy and we would sit
there in his Japanese restaurant and
finish a bottle of whiskey and he would
talk philosophy in Japanese I guess you
move from that sense of wow look at me
I'm speaking the foreign language to
where you're just communicating and then
at that point it's no longer that sense
of wow it's just it's just you are able
to communicate with more different
people it's fun to be with Chinese
people with French people with Spanish
people with I'm looking forward to going
to Ukraine and speaking Russian and
Ukrainian and it just opens up more
channels of communication I can't think
of one particular incident or experience
yeah my famous says you can eat Han you
can't speak yourself a very long hello
Bangladesh you think article 13 will
have any impact on link it's the yo
copyright directive requiring proactive
copyright filters I mean I don't know
whether it would affect us obviously he
tried to stress on people that they
shouldn't upload things for which they
don't have the copyright when we are
made aware of them we remove them I
don't know anything more than that why
would we are talking to ourselves we can
keep a long conversation then we start
to think we are not good at learning and
we talk with people we do it right yeah
it's difficult to speak to yourself I
mean what are you gonna talk about again
there's so many different things that
people do it's not for me to say that
it's a good idea or not a good idea yeah
yeah I had an April Fool's video where I
announced that I was gonna stop trying
to learn any more languages because
English was good enough or something
like that yeah there's time to live
[Music]
okay yeah Kevin says you got this long
haul and so lots of chance to listen I
agree with you
hi from Morocco you know what I really
enjoyed visiting Morocco quite different
from what I expected much greener I had
this idea that Morocco was some kind of
dry place on the edge of the desert when
we took a bus from Fez up to chef
Chauhan it was all green rich
agriculture and of course a different
culture very much different culture but
they're interesting friendly people
ah Steve I never see you speak Arabic I
will say Ida Ida I shall be a staff iam
aha Sofia an axe our little akka right
now I my hair is not so good but I will
I wa was there a noticeable improvement
in your comprehension after that I have
the sense that I had a greater sense of
how the language works
I wasn't adding words I was perhaps
confirming some words time hotel I mean
there's so many things that I think so
many things in language during that you
don't get an immediate sort of effect
it's like this idea that like I believe
for example that learning Persian and
Arabic together
of course it limits my improvement in
either one but I think it makes my brain
more attentive to language period I
noticed things better and I think it's
going to be very good for me in terms of
training my brain for dealing with a
variety of languages sounds ways of
expressing things and so far okay Ian
thank you I have caliber but I can't get
the
file out of Kindle in two caliber so
that's what I'm trying to figure out Oh
have you heard about Matt vias he's a
polyglot who's telling us quickly
growing following that you don't need
comprehensible input and you should
meditate six months before starting a
study I won't be trying that but there's
all kinds of different ways that work
for people okay
I think the best method for learning
grammar is to just get some short text
and examine every sentence using some
short grammar book the trouble with that
is you can understand you can understand
if we talk for example Slavic languages
you can understand the reasons for the
different cases are no more difficult to
understand the aspects of verbs but to
actually produce it every time you use
the language that's difficult and that's
where you have to train certain habits
and that's what for listening and
reading is so powerful and eventually
speaking listening I mean listening
listening without reading just listening
I don't do a lot of listening while
reading I give you some in Arabic
because the Arabic script is still so
foreign to me but otherwise when I read
I read a link and when I listen I'm
doing something else I find that the
great advantage of listening is that you
can do it
while doing other things you become a
hero to your wife because you're much
more willing to do household chores
while listening okay can't afford to
darling I mean there's not much we can
do really for people who can't afford
the ten dollars a month wait till you
can't afford it
in the meantime you're welcome to
download whatever we have a thing could
use it for your own purposes I took your
advice and talked to a teacher on at
least I talked you've created
when you talk about listening and
reading how important it is do you first
read or do you listen and then read it
rather I do both sometimes I listen
first in order to become curious
curiosity is a great motivator so if I
listen I really don't understand it then
I'm quite curious to read it and look up
the words and sometimes I read first and
look up the words and review the words
then I listen then I go back to read I
don't think it really matters I'm from
Brazil Japan hi I'm Mona piroshki
the easiest King encounter is use the
desktop Kindle application
oke unless I downloaded the desktop
Kindle application and then I tried to
open this Arabic book and you know the
seven Habits and they told me that they
don't support a camera what they said
but you know my system doesn't handle
this or something like that so it
doesn't seem to want to read the Arabic
font and so then it sends you off to up
all these help places where you just get
a lot of standard answers okay if I put
five hours a day into reading and
listening French every day can I get the
b2 level after five months
I don't know Luka I don't know what your
native language is but I think if you
put in five hours a day there's a very
good chance that you will get to be -
you say you never reviewers on their own
then how do you review new words no no I
say I review randomly and I review when
I turn the page in a lesson
so if or sometimes you'll see the little
yellow link number at the top of a
lesson that tells you how many yellow
links that are there 10 or 20 or
whatever and I'll go through those so
it's very much of a random thing related
to a content that I'm listening to and
studying if you listen then you don't
have to understand what
continue listening and eventually I'll
understand no I don't recommend that at
all I find that is very inefficient I
have been listening to this Arabic the
seven secrets of Highly successful
people because the voice is pleasant and
that's so important this presence I
listen to and I pick up stuff but I'm
now very motivated to read that and so
ultimately when you listen you don't
understand that's good because now
you're curious to read it so I only I
want to listen to stuff where I can
access the text and hopefully try to get
you know to where I understand more of
it don't just listen and listen and
listen hope you're gonna get somewhere I
think that's a very very inefficient
approach which is signify Magli of Leo
Chan
Hiroshi tell of Ecstasy Baba yeah Jung
is now you we share corrosion anyway
what do you think about reading books
with parallel text there are books in
Greek with the English types right below
it using link for Greek and really
liking it
yeah I mean it's it's another way of
doing it especially at the early stages
eventually I like to get into the target
language alone but I by the way I I did
it darlink for Greek and I enjoyed are
many stories which were done for us by a
guy who I found on that of work and I
thought he did a great job and I was
being able to hold the conversational
language at reading pretty well but not
being able to understand the news or
very fast poking TV shows being on a
high level or not well I think you can
be a b2 and have trouble following TV
shows you know there's that whole range
between b1 and b2 like a strong v2
should be able to understand spoken TV
shows but it takes a long time to get
from b1 to b2 b1 you can kind of
converse b2 you should be able to
understand TV show so I would say you're
a b-1 and a half if you can reading is
easier and holy conversation depends on
what self
matter is but understand the news and
spoken TV yeah that's that requires b2
in my opinion what do you think about
watching movies with subs in the same
language I think that's a good thing to
do I think that's a good thing to do
what's even better is if you can access
those movies with subs and using our
link extension important you know from
the browser important it into link then
you can actually review the text in and
take the time to learn some of the words
that are there what tips do you have for
speaking to your first tutor I would say
first of all relax I think the onus is
on the tutor to make you feel
comfortable to get you to speak to ask
you questions to you know to keep track
of your mistakes to send you a good
report
hopefully with audio as well just to
keep you talking yeah yes I learned
Korean but I don't speak it as well as I
would like and I'm gonna get back to
Korea how important is it to be focused
when listening I find my mind sometimes
- yeah you're gonna drift like it's it's
not possible to be totally focused but
that's where you know if it's five hours
you know you're gonna fade in and out
fade in and out but a lot of it is gonna
remain and so I don't think you should
be too concerned about staying focused
allow yourself to be unfocused
okay looks like we don't have enough a
lot more we have no more questions so
with that I'm canoe I get off early
today again to my Brazilian fence
friends I sure enjoyed visiting Brazil
blah blah blah kinase is explores me
da14 or cheese course is Korean
difficult I found it very difficult and
and but link is better now and we plus
we have the mini stories of Korea
so I'm determined to get back to Korean
and take myself up to a higher level
than I am at right now
how many novels approximately read in
languages that you speak the best um
well I mean I'd love lots of novels in
French I've read a couple of novels in
Chinese Japanese I've read more novels
in Spanish German Swedish not so much
novels but history books I can't tell
you how many Dutch yeah you know I've
looked at Dutch it's just it's just not
a priority but I feel I could learn it
fairly quickly
yeah not no immediate plans would you
rate some languages as harder than
others absolutely absolutely and the
best example of all is Persian and
Arabic Persian isn't for me as a speaker
of European indo-european languages
version is much easier than Arabic the
writing system is more consistent and
the structure is more similar to
languages that I have been exposed to so
for me there's no question that version
is much easier than Arabic but I think
it's largely a function of which
languages you already know so maybe
they're not absolutely more difficult
but relative to languages you know those
that are similar to languages that you
know are typically going to be easier
crack where Sam is floors nearly 30 you
can't say like I find in Arabic quite
difficult Chinese had the problem of
characters Slavic languages have the
problems now we just have in a way the
more the most finicky grammar little
details that you have to try to master
in order to speak correctly and that's
what I'm gonna focus on in the month of
May ah what do you think of Envy in the
polyglot community and the top of your
quality versus quantity in Langley
friend okay
I'm not aware of the envy in the
polyglot community it might be there
when I hear someone speak there
language as well I am full of admiration
I just I'm just I think it's wonderful
when I attend these polyglot conferences
I do not have the impression that
there's envy I find that there is a lot
of mutual support and neutral admiration
whether that person speaks two languages
three languages eight languages I don't
think at least I'm not aware of that as
a factor
I made a new goal of reading theater
downlink for four weeks and I thought I
made a big improvement to my speak it's
great I'm not sure why this is you know
Jason
hey man you have to you know Steven
crime is a very serious person the the
fact is that when we have meaningful
input listening reading we are sending
signals to the brain the brain has to
deal with it
create a neural network to deal with
this new language that is essentially
how we increase our at least potential
in the language now ultimately to speak
you have to start outputting all that
but you gotta build up this capability
which is vocabulary which is familiarity
with structure and that's dumb through
listening your EP so it's not surprising
that if you do a lot of it every day you
will improve that's always been my
experience do you listen to the podcast
for your Japanese no Japanese because
you know when I was in Japan they didn't
have podcasts I did a lot of listening
to you know I had this cassette tape
series for example from NHK the national
broadcaster in Japan on show on
okie-dokie the history of the Showa era
which I listened to many many many times
long before you know Stephen Gresham I
had this sort of naturally realized that
reading and listening is a very powerful
way of learning do you know how they're
probably glad to use the same method as
you I think all polygons starting from
Catalan in the 20th century famous
Hungarian polyglot lady rely on input
whatever other things they do they all
rely on input as the only
as the main way that that a language
that is new to you can come into use
good do you know huh do you use Google
Translate Oh
Google Translate I use it one of the
problems with Persian is but I use
Google Translate for Persian it's okay I
have in fact I have loaded up loaded if
you look in link there are three other
dictionaries I can't remember their
names that I use for Persian Google
Translate seems to be the best it's a
problem I would say so far I found
person the language that has the least
dictionary support but I'm managing I'm
managing I'm learning Persian faster
than Arabic simply because Persian is
easier uh have you ever heard about
virtually native he says that reading is
much more important than listening uh
you know my own you know I can only talk
about my own experience first of all
listening is something I can do while
doing other things I can listen in the
car I can listen while exercising I can
listen to are cleaning up and so that
dramatically increases the time
available for language learning now even
if theoretically reading is better and
I'm not sure it is that means I have to
sit down and read I can't read while
driving I can't read while exercising so
practically from a practical point of
view listening is the most powerful
learning activity because it's so
portable second of all I find that if I
read and listen or listen and read the
to reinforce each other and therefore
they have to be looked at together when
I read I am almost not really
subconsciously I'm some vocalizing I
have to have some sense of how those
words are pronounced and so therefore if
I listen before reading then it gives me
more momentum for my reading I find that
meeting increases your vocabulary but
listening prepares you for speaking so I
think they are both important
I'm wondering where to find interesting
content interesting content in which
language I Google sometimes use Google
Translate to translate a subject matter
that I'm interested in into the target
language and then google and see what I
what language took you the longest to
learn well I've been a long time with
Korean and I'm nowhere near where I want
to be and to cook what happened dataview
Moscow less I muchos there's many but
there's no real true code there's no
real trick
escucha Alea mooch would learn german is
a useful to use a dictionary you know to
me a dictionary is a tool you get in and
out of in order to get through the
content that you're reading and
listening to you won't get a real good
sense of the scope of words the scope of
meaning until you have a lot of exposure
to the language so what dictionaries are
there I don't use the traditional
dictionary because it takes too long to
look up a dictionary and then we forget
immediately as soon as we close the
dictionary we forget that's why I prefer
to use online tools online dictionaries
and stay in the content and get at more
content and eventually I get a sense of
what the words mean so kind of we as
ecology lots xx don't speak them all and
you'll say oh how important what you say
it is a beginner to hit the tones right
in Chinese you won't hit the cones right
in Chinese as a beginner it takes a long
time for the brain to get used to these
tones and if you deal with them as
phrases and you get the rhythm of the
language your tones will gradually
improve or if I have to admit that you
know Arabic script shows up a such small
font and given the difficulty that I
have reading Arabic I can't necessarily
do it on the fly
oh no this is pirate version chan chan
direct what the Farsi
boy had go ahead
me media immediately anyway do you have
languages that when you started it it
felt right and it came easier to you not
really they're all they all have their
difficulties why do we speak so well
with some ladies but we struggle with
others if the language is the same in
this case it's not are they emotions are
very important it's important when we
listen that we enjoy the voice it's
important that we enjoy their content
and some people make us feel comfortable
they sorta send out signals that give us
confidence and some people make us
stressful and so it's very absolutely
true that it's easier to speak with some
people than with others this solvent yes
this shirt is from Salvador Bahia
we enjoyed it there we we flew into
salvador from real first day went down
to the lower town wandered around a bit
took the elevator up to the top area the
historical part of Bahia it's a colonial
Portuguese colonial town lots of history
probably the the street sellers there
are a little more aggressive than other
parts of Brazil but on Allinol and and
we explored restaurants near our hotel
and music eating are like we walked from
our hotel to a restaurant that was
recommended in the bird cafes with with
live bands and they're just so much
music in Brazil we enjoyed it let's see
what else we have how do you memorize do
you think there is a ratio between age
and language learning ability I'm 73 I
think I'm a better language learner now
then when I was in my place I think that
as a general rule it's like anything
else if you compare for example if I
were to take up a new sport at my age I
could have more difficult it gives the
body you know is not as supple as it
once was but when it comes to language
learning
you just have to activate the brain and
you can learn
at any age how do you memorize words I
don't memorize I make no effort to
memorize it simply through the exposure
to the language through listening and
reading occasional random review of
words that gradually all of a sudden I
know more words my statistics link tell
me in other words and I find that my
page of link is all of a sudden has
fewer blue words more white words even
new content that I bring in even
difficult content from al Jazeera
lots of white words that's how it's it's
almost like a magic process but it's not
one of memorizing thank you gotta go
early bye for now to the day probably go
to do you got I live normally in
Vancouver but right now I'm in Palm
Springs California because my wife
doesn't like Vancouver when it rains all
the time how do you correct these
complicated mistakes when it comes to
Slavic languages I'm going to find that
out
one thing I did not have before is the
many stories the many stories focused on
verbs a lot of the problems in err in
Slavic languages relate to verbs verbs
of motion and aspects of verbs and even
the case endings that relate to verbs
and so oh I'm gonna listen to these mini
stories in Russian and Ukrainian
possibly polished with greater attention
to the Indians and stuff like that to
try to get useful more so that they
become more natural to me it's not no
matter the explanations have seen the
explanations many many times it's a
matter of developing habits and I'm
going to end up in the video crane at
the Ukrainian language and culture
school there that I visited a couple of
years ago and we're gonna have intensive
period to see if I can be you know
elevated and I might even ask the school
there to give me a rating on the common
European framework am i b1 b2 where am I
in my Ukrainian and Russian so we will
see Sofia how useful is reading out loud
I don't read out loud but
people like to do it - El Salvador -
Costa Rica let's see how to avoid
jumping from language to language
without the language core I don't
understand the question
if you are learning for enjoyment as I
do then you move on when you move on and
I go probably my plan is to get back to
my Slavic languages at the end of April
that means I will leave Persian and
Arabic in a very unfinished low level
but that's what I'm intending to do and
I will go back to them as I will go back
to Korean MX you know that's my plan
starting in June which I left at a sort
of an intermediate level so they're all
you can get back them whenever you want
unless you have to do them for school or
for your work what do you think about
modelling dictionaries I don't use them
because I really want just a quick hint
as to what a word means so that I can
stay in the content that I'm using that
I'm reading that I'm listening to I
don't want to go to a monolingual
dictionary where I have to look up even
more words to understand the explanation
I just want a quick suggestion of what
mainly this word means and then I look
back into the content that I'm using and
I try to figure out and I might it might
be fuzzy it might be incorrect it all
doesn't matter because in the long run
through more and more exposure more and
more of the sort of scope of these words
and meaning of these words is gonna
become clear to me Oh Thank You Sofia I
hope to have a good week ahead how to
build language core I don't know what
language core is but I'm not a proponent
of the idea that you sort of master
anything you build your language
capability your potential through
massive exposure to the language do you
think that writing can help thinking in
the language and with that help help you
speak easily yeah writing is a great
thing to do it's not something that I do
because it requires a lot of patience
it's easier just to speak but obviously
when you are writing you take more time
you look
I make a greater effort to use the
language correctly it's certainly a good
thing to do I wrote when I studied
Chinese born achieves who is arrested at
Monticello who's a tea party circular
this did Hebrew help me with Arabic it
was my first exposure to so many
languages going from right to left but I
did so little Hebrew that I don't think
it had any major impact on my Arabic I'm
going to see my friends Nigerian family
also I have chunked myself to learn
through conversational Hungarian tree
monster for you we do have someone who
has promised to provide us with many
stories in Hungarian if we get those we
will upload Hungarian um ok how old were
you when you started getting interested
in languages yeah probably a good thing
I had the opportunity to travel I
studied in France I think it is an
advantage but I don't think it's a
condition Chun Tong Heena and o fan ok
thank you
you can be very sure we fit for a 73
year old what exercise do you do how
often and you think exercise affects
your language right from pair yeah in
terms of I'd like to do something every
day so you know here in Palm Springs
where I live we have a little gym I go
down there i variate between certain
stepper treadmill weights that kind of
thing I might jump in there outdoor pool
and swim then I have other routines that
I do for example where I have a routine
where I do you know push-ups
running on the spot squats running on
the spot burpees runny nose but plank so
that's four items and then I did that
four times
I have other you know I try to vary it
up but just try to get in half an hour
45 minutes sometimes 15 minutes a day
but try to do it almost every day
don't jog as much because I get very
stiff ID Banton since I'm too lazy to
stretch I end up feeling very stifling
around so I run the sometimes but not
too often I used to run a lot more do
they try to memorize verb conjugations
to speak with people and grandmother's
or you just read and listen and grasp it
in that way yeah verb conjugations
certainly are a problem I I don't
memorize them I have tried and verb
conjugations or declension tables in
German or Slavic languages it's the same
idea it's a table of different endings
and I have found it difficult to
memorize them but you know at link we do
have sort of a grammar tab we have
dictionaries which take you to these
tables come on text Reverso is very good
but in that regard
other conjugating dictionaries so when i
see a form of a word i sometimes go to
the table see where it fits in the table
come back to the text so I think this
term sporadic exposure to the
conjugation tables gradually helps you
to get a better sense
I also save phrases and I try to listen
for the phrase so that these things
start to become more natural I think
it's a bit like tones in Chinese it's
very difficult to nail them on the fly
if you're sort of dealing with them as
individual units you have to kind of
deal with it as part of longer phrases
okay how many languages are you a see to
it I don't know I don't know if I'm the
only one that I would be close to see to
in is French so I see one baby in French
then Japanese and Mandarin sort of a
high B to low C one and I think I don't
know I said I've never had myself tested
Keith Hamilton I'm a teacher in Negro
I'm gonna be in hiepro on the 16th no
yeah 16th to 18th of May if you want to
get together we can have a cup of coffee
okay
do you understand every word no but
I think it's useful to listen you know
if you're gonna do a listening marathon
I guess there's two situations one is
material where you understand 8090
percent and so then you're focusing on
the structure of the language but I also
have listen to material where I only
understand 20% 30% because I sent the
light that told the voice the sort of
musicality of it but in that case I do
want to get to the text so I can look up
the words I I for example my 5 hours of
listening was mini stories where I
basically knew it was listening through
them all for the 10:50 time is it
possible to learn German in one year yes
is it off you start with a single as a
basic fundamental learning language for
sure in fact I find all of those starter
books are equal do you think it would be
better to intensely take along a
two-month break when you're learning a
really tough language or should you keep
personal I mean it depends if you're
getting frustrated then you should take
a break
otherwise the more you do the faster
you'll get there after how long this
start comfortable well I can't answer
that question I can't answer but I at
one point I gave up trying to memorize
the conjugation to her they declension
tables and I went out in found
secondhand bookstores in Vancouver and
found cassette tapes and lots of content
and listened and read and read and these
were textbooks with you know word lists
and I just exposed myself to more and
more of the language and you know a
month I felt more comfortable what
languages are spoken in Vancouver Lots
you know Chinese Farsi Tagalog of course
English question out of this what kind
of food do you eat why all kinds of food
all kinds of food I like fish I like
vegetables not a big meat eater but I do
eat some meat I eat
you know obviously western food French
food right over in you know comment
okras een not a big fan of fast food try
to keep it healthy for those who want to
improve English poke em search the power
of words
okay iced tea I have a 180 HP Conley
what do you think of that very good how
many language do you speak you know I
think I can speak 10 or 12 quite easily
and the others I would need to work on
hello is studying three four hours a day
affected yes the more you study the more
you will learn the faster you go improve
okay I am gonna stop here thank you very
much and what do I think of Luka Lamba
yeah he is a phenomenal polygon and a
very nice guy okay resident do not
confuse Arabic and Persian I don't
confuse them in fact if anything the
Arabic words in Persian are helpful
makes it easier to remember them
students enjoy don't have any learning
link in China without using a VPN any
solutions cheers from Sonya I have no
solutions that's a very technical thing
I mentioned that to our technical people
but I don't know that there is any
solution to that okay yeah I think that
I got my share and I know okay that's it
bye for now